okay I don't want to touch my dick hey
what's going on everybody for first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones it's not only the hottest wings
but even how to twist Oh today you're
joined today what in all Ari I'm such a
fan of you
nori I'm such a fan or another I'll says
okay I'm sorry he's a hip-hop legend yes
he's a favorite drunk uncle yeah well I
am here Joe yes if you want to catch him
he's got the video podcast series drink
champs Nouri welcome to the show thank
you so much and just so you know I don't
want to plug anything I'm just so much
of a fan of this show
Norah I just wanted to come sit down and
be scared cuz I'm terrified
well let's talk about our shows because
I kind of think that you and I are kind
of kindred spirits and sort of a TV
personality way and I think that our
shows are kind of like twins that were
separated at birth I believe you and we
have a lot of the same problems too many
pool sticks not enough pool Oh Cole not
just not enough oh yes and I'm not gonna
lie I always see the black background I
had no idea that you actually do it
where there's other workers out there
like living their life look at drink
chaps like it's the same thing but it's
just with alcohol so what we're gonna do
run do a special edition okay okay every
time we go me and you gonna take a shot
of tiger bone okay all right so we got
you got a shot glasses and would you
like to pour can you pork yeah because
I'm gonna be honest we're gonna be
modest yeah yeah yeah I like it Alexa
cuz um I'm so scared to death you
brought the surgical gloves
yes I've run a search who loves I
watched man vs. food
okay so watches fantastic gotta take a
shot Tiger bone okay all right dad we
gotta show you how to do it I die I die
now I life is [ __ ] them strange shot
that's a chase with hot sauce very
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] up nore we're
going to places all huh yeah sure
I've been some so much a fan of you cuz
you know what no one can finish your
questions after this you can I like your
style
yeah gasps Emile let me ask you this
Noorie because you know you have a show
called drink champs and then you mix in
a destination food show given what you
like to eat you were once in all around
that 300-pound mark before what are you
doing to balance it out now I have to
balance it out because of the fact that
um I having so much fun
prior to that I didn't have um ooh my
strategy was not to touch my face at all
but just did but that's sriracha yeah
really and I'm such a fan of when people
come here and they don't know like
Michael Rapaport didn't know right Eddie
hyung didn't know dj khaled had no idea
t-pain no but his method just didn't
work cuz what he did he sipped milk
first his whole thing was like if I
quote my stomach with milk I'll be good
it didn't work it didn't work uh yeah I
just feel like drink champs is the same
thing so let's pour another shot now
this time I poured it you see how light
is very latest it's Jeff so now you pour
a shot and I need another red cuz i
watch the show so much I need another
red um it feels like nobody's prepared
yeah okay look at your name is Sean tase
your name Shante she just looks like a
Shante
is it hot for me I love this show I hate
milk
you're probably the closest thing that
we have to a hip hop booze historian
so what I want to do is bring you some
and you put like dramatic music like
look at my face look I like that I'm
actually working on a show right now
let's start shooting a pilot right here
because what I want to do is I want to
show you some hip hop dream bring out
the UM the BAP top the laptops coming
out the laptop and I want you to rate
them on how hip-hop they are when I
watch it it seems like the laptop is
like like over there I didn't know what
that's like this close that close okay
hi Stan Kristoff I was so disappointed
when Krystal said that um they didn't
want to support up hip-hop I like
Cristal
I think her style is a great drink but
once they said that they wasn't fans of
people from hip-hop embracing the brand
embracing the brand I feel like it was
racist
but when they said hip-hop it was like
that's even more racist to me because
hip-hop is now no race saints a night uh
in Queens bridge and left for AK city
call it the Danny Danny means like a
girl shut up Kenny Anderson Shani
andaman shockin Ali ocularly Kenny
Aniston Kenny Smith but also uh we don't
want to forget Queensbridge nas Mobb
Deep screwball those are the people that
actually named it Danny and then after
that came back to left back came back to
the Bronx and we all just named it Danny
say nice but it's still a terrible drink
how hip-hop is it is super hip-hop
wu-tang made a commercial for it that
should be clear gin and juice no gin and
juice is before my time
still hip-hop when snoop came to our
show we actually try to get gin and
juice and he was like what year y'all is
no time Donna she was like get all
secular yeah yeah we had Bob Bayon and
snoop just looked at us like what super
chong tojon nephew Hennessy Hennessy was
my go-to drink and a night
okay I forget which one is this my face
towel or my hand towel that's a bad
thing to confess a bad thing and I watch
the show so much that's the whole thing
it's like whatever plan you have it goes
out the window there's that Mike Tyson
quote about like everyone has a plan
until they get punched in the face
Hennessey I love Hennessey the problem
with me with Hennessey is our blackout
that's not really a good thing when
you're CEO how hip-hop is a super
hip-hop
okay so this is an Incredible Hulk
Hennessey with hypnotic oh yeah he's
terrible terrible terrible I can't do it
was that created at Justin's I heard a
story that was like kind of my orange
balloon was created in justice which is
pops restaurant for the folks out there
yes big up big up puff cuz that was my
favorite restaurant Justin's I don't I
don't know if people know I heard that
you used to break glasses on the horn
no you listen this guy's [ __ ] a lot
of people understand that the reason why
I came here is because he's like nod
watt nod wad no [ __ ] that nobody else
alone I used to miss reading I was the
weak ice and Popish the call man be like
you know what the [ __ ] are you doing I'm
like yelling what the [ __ ] if you were
Greek here I was lying
[Music]
yeah electro one Yucatec oh you gotta go
it seems like you're positioning
yourself to be the beef Squasher of
record and hip hop trying I'm trying I'm
trying
what is the William take a shot
rejection what is the mediation that
you're most proud of
Oh jay-z a Fat Joe sorry yeah I can tell
you story oh oh oh hot for me listen oh
I can't
I like a [ __ ] because nobody acts like
a [ __ ] till after this well I just love
you so much no I love you too Sal oh so
alright mr. Shah I contact oh you
remember Fat Joe calls me fragile never
called me so Fat Joe calls me it's like
Joe
how did you get in contact with jay-z
I'm like uh you don't get contact with
jay-z he gets got yeah me and jay-z
are first two shows together when ain't
on this is beautiful
I was already work I was over there with
when jay-z I ain't old [ __ ] started
working was the same time la la started
working so I've been on the road with
this guy like you know my default so
when Fat Joe finally told me and I was
like are you sure he's like I'm sure my
heart my mom was doing all type of [ __ ]
so I'm like Fat Joe you serious he's
like I'm serious and I called Mitch
bleep Malik or Jay
I gave me a freaking Fat Joe the number
that's why Jay says on the record
man Bleek hip fat go on a jack that's
the most proudest they know because
those are two people are both respect to
be bar both like to be bought both you
know what to prosper and they squash the
beef on the stuff of me
[Music]
pain is good louisiana-style you gotta
listen there's no one who came on the
show and never um address this guy's
face it's a good album er you know what
I mean it's just one of those things
that just catches you look this is exact
same [ __ ] I say don't drink jams this is
why I love this guy cuz he he has the
same exact method it flies off Sean
Evans let me just show you focus on me
for one second it's terrible by the way
that's awesome
there's nothing been good but Sean Evans
is the best [ __ ] host on internet let
me tell you why you're a [ __ ] King oh
[ __ ] god I can't handle this because
whenever white guy says dude like a
black dude it's the equivalent to when a
black guy says [ __ ] right right and
then listen if you watch hot ones this
at least we hunted thousand do those
dudes dude dude dude dude dude yeah hey
dude yeah yeah I guess I didn't take a
shower
sanal back at Sean I miss Willy plan not
to put but I think when I just took the
shot my whole [ __ ] Oh
[Music]
hottest [ __ ] it's interesting to see a
lot of artists get into the podcast game
it's interesting to see Joe Budden do it
it's interesting to see for all do it
it's interesting to see nori do it what
do you like about being on the other
side of the table
I had no idea what the [ __ ] I was doing
but you studied journalism yeah you have
a journalism background I actually do my
shows in jail and credits count the
credits count the credits count I had a
choice between social studies was
actually absolutely love but for some
reason I picked [ __ ] journalism that
day I applied that to The Breakfast Club
interviews I applied that to hot 97 Ebro
in the morning interviews and
it just spiraled out to people saying
you should do your own [ __ ] I just
didn't know what it was I'm glad I got a
UH a great partner named DJ efn and he
waited for me to be ready and this is
how we have King jams for 20 years
you've been hanging out with these guys
you've been talking to these guys when
they sit down they're naturally
comfortable with you because they know
you but you don't think injera advantage
because everybody I help swings I think
it's just different let's say you had
Kanye West today on drinks with you be
excited for that interview would you be
anxious about it would you be worried
about it what would your mindset be
going ah be worried about it after him
walking offstage as I mean like if you
catch him now in this moment cuz
sometimes it could be about
circumstances and I mean and you're like
I have this person in front of me so if
I had Kanye right now today I would be
worried if I have a relationship with
you and here's the thing so many people
will come and say I love they drink
champs and I want to do business with
the drink chest but then they'll come up
late and I hate that [ __ ]
kind of my [ __ ] ten minutes late I'm so
pissed
Noorie weren't you like a half hour late
for this yeah but I'm your friend
so this is hot ones this is my hot sauce
you made this yourself I did not it's
not like I was in a bathtub like
churning it or whatever I'm curious what
you think nori
spicy after this I watch the show so
much
I know exact to a smart expect speaking
of drink champs one of the most
interesting questions that you ask all
the industry batsu yes yeah that's a
very important question that you ask but
I think the most important question that
you ask is who is your favorite CEO that
you work for yes so what I want to do
then you're a real fan Thank You Sean
huh you know what it is your EB cuz we
see we're just I die
we're just sorry I'm such a fan of you
and like why and I don't expect you to
be a fan of me so when you say that back
to me it's like so [ __ ] awesome and I
wanna call you do [ __ ] for like I should
say dude 300,000 times alright dude got
it to do but I want to do is just show
you some moguls mobile some guys who
behind-the-scenes or some of the biggest
players in the game alright and then I
just wanna get the first thing that
comes to your mind okay yep let's go
LA Reid he need to give me a deal right
now right now LA we you want to get off
that indeed yeah in this man opinion
then if it is suck what he's doing with
Tribe Called Quest what he's doing with
Busta Rhymes what he's doing with a
college future that's the place it why
does everybody Bert ball how once we are
going little calls from his [ __ ]
vampire he's not stop calling me about
bringing my [ __ ] to YouTube and I really
I really just enjoy respect what he's
doing and Leos my man
Suge Knight I actually um was on a
private plane one day sure was on the
other private plane and we actually had
to actually like land and switch planes
I was like sure push up and I'm like a
hundred eighty pounds at this time yeah
and sugars just looking at me like I was
like what's a real [ __ ] astok I didn't
say that but in my mind I said bitch-ass
[ __ ]
so that counts accounts I was like
Jordan
I don't tomorrow we got like 75 I got
people from the Bronx one five seven
inch Arad murder unit I got people left
fracking of people McQueen's bring up in
where's way
and we just so deep and she just looked
at us and just gave us a file and it's
like I gotta get out of here and that
was it and that was it but we thought
that should I don't want to test my dick
what a Def Jam Vendetta get wrong about
your fighting style oh I forgot how good
you are yeah in a good actually a good
knock out of your knock out guy in my
past life
[Music]
Boop I love it
so you felt like you should have had
like a nice solid put your jaw through
the back your skull punch that's a fact
if you weren't playing with your
character who is your favorite character
to play with Rob Lurie but your nori if
you weren't playing with nori who is
your favorite character to put it on
nori nori who's your favorite guy to
beat up nor sometimes I talk to like NBA
players about 2k and NBA players think
that it's kind of corny like if you play
for the Warriors they don't think that
you should play with the Warriors in the
NBA service does an NBA scoring play is
a corny
[Music]
Michael gotta down nori hitting yeah God
God something I love about drink champs
is the frequency and casual way that you
just dropped like I was hanging out at
Diddy's house I love that
and when you think about Diddy whether
it's in the boardroom
whether it's at his house whether it's
in a club you gotta respect this [ __ ]
dude
cuz you know what he just stare you
stuck you like the hands you like the
hands I get a lot of heat for the hands
people give me [ __ ] for the hands I love
it do another shot oh sorry good
personal hot ones coming on done
take a lap nori oh yeah yeah
I can do is never watch the show they
don't know the laugh is very important
what stands out to you about Diddy the
[ __ ]
why don't have a gloves this is not this
is not right Oh top one top one top one
is terrible why my we spend a lot of
time thinking about our dream guest so
Alexa Chung bill burr the rock if you're
watching this holler at me
who's your white whale on drink champs
who's like shot of it no way
first off that's not a big deal I'll
book a flight to Miami in two seconds we
can do drink Julie give me your white
whale give me your Moby Dick nori my
friend you want friend add a little de
nori we're friends but who's somebody
I'm drink champs that you want who's
like your guy Sappho weed you want Seth
Rogen we want Seth Rogen on this show -
can you come on my show - any time you
want doing it you can go take your turn
[Music]
well this is my last so decide your last
night your last second class second time
this far
so this is hot and Nuria know when you
swallow it's gonna be an issue you you
calmly boss Oh - terrible I know that
you listen to the web I know that the
drunk uncle was sort of informed by the
web so I know that you listen but if
you're messing around in the comments
there's got to be things that annoy you
that bother you
that piss you off what do you read that
kind of gets into your head a little bit
I don't we [ __ ] but even if you poke
down there there's got to be things that
but what do people say oh I'll be honest
[Music]
there's no comments that pissed me off
because I actually don't read the
comments to piss me off
well it's dad that's dad
I feel like nori if I'm being real the
tracks have kind of come off the train
or the trains have kind of cut the train
has kind of come off the tracks here
we've been slugging Hot Sauce taking
shots to Tiger bone and I don't have a
lot less we don't have a lot to give at
this point but look at this [ __ ] damn
so now a hot sauce no no I appreciate it
this is because like I love you I love
you so much too buddy solo salute doing
some I have no idea why I'm still here
no one can finish your questions after
this you can I like your style
you're gassing me up nori nori nori why
are you cleaning that witness got that
sauce on it
all right no I'm gonna be very fun
loader cameras are rolling slide right
left we gonna let their almond oh right
I'm removed ideal one album yeah all
right
laughs no way I'm stopped all right
let's take a little island Oh cuz you've
been drinking water with that hot over
take another shot of this
okay you go home I'm leaving believe me
a minute - yeah let me get through the
interview kind of fell off the rails but
you [ __ ] clean the wings Emma mommy -
glad we talked your shots my mouth is
all some tire this camera that camera
that camera or that camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life we are hot once it's true god
damn it and I'm going home today after I
finish shot once and my mouth is still
hot as [ __ ]
what it was it my apps told you Smeagol
it's a root it violated you you violated
me let's go find amore
well you're still my friend you know
you're my friend too bro
[Music]